I'm in a terminal. I'm going to go ahead and fire up Python.
I'm going to show you how to use Python to do hashing for you
because we're going to be doing a lot of this in this class.
So one thing we can use is hashlib, and hashlib has a couple hashes available to you.
You've got md5, sha1, 256. Those are the ones we just talked about.
So let's go ahead and get the md5 of something.
The way we do that is we say, x = hashlib.md5, and we say "foo".
Okay, so now x is this hash object, and the way we get something useful out of this
is we call the hex digest function on it.
If we call hex digest on the result of md5, we get this string.
This is the md5 hash of this string "foo."
If I were to change--let's do this all in one line--let's say, hashlib.md5 "hello hello"--
oops! "hello hello" and call hex digest on it.
We can see our hash.
Now if I were to just change one of these characters.
Let's change to a capital O.
We can see our hash completely changes.
See, we add f5 to it, blah, blah, blah. 263 here.
So that's a neat property of this particular hashing function,
and if we were to change this back to "hello hello", we get our original hash.
What's nice about a hash like hashlibmd5 is it's available on every system.
If I type--if I hash "hello hello" on any system with md5, we're going to get the same result.
That's pretty cool.